foreign
they have been you know very known to
meddle in the political Affairs so
that's something which has been going on
since the uh since last 75 years since
country essentially came into beam
[Music]
yeah
you know they're doing everything to
make sure that I get out of the race
2011 onwards
um he started Gathering more momentum
and that momentum that children support
that he had was kind of appropriated and
captured by the military at the time and
eventually in 2018 the elections took
place Imran Khan managed to win those
elections he has a very clear popularity
in the country there is absolutely no
denying that however his Rivals
constantly kept saying that this this
kind of Victory he won more than 120
seats it was only possible with the help
of military like military tricked these
elections
[Music]
obvious
Juan has been out on the streets
demanding early elections and during
this while obviously he has been
criticized in the government but he is
particularly
specifically targeting the military and
the military leadership as the one who
has architect of his house church he
constantly keeps saying that Pakistan
military Chief is out to get him so his
argument of often goes about targeting
individuals not necessarily the idea of
how entrenched military is countries
politics you cannot wish where the role
of military in Pakistan because it's
entrenched for 70 years so you know his
idea of Civilian Supremacy is slightly
skewed that way
military as I said is such a strong
influence in the country and so deeply
entrenched that in some ways basically
what I say is that house always wins so
in terms of prediction I still believe
that house which is military
establishment in the country is going to
win but the kind of challenge that Imran
has really given to them It prepares
that house might win most likely will
win but it will have its walls Windows
pretty pretty damaged
thank you